Joe Biden has been doing fairly well in
many polls but is he too confident
campaigning from his basement the
presumptive Democratic nominee making
another gas by mixing up jobs data with
coronavirus deaths watch we're in the
middle of a pandemic that had cost us
more than 85,000 jobs as of today lives
of millions of people millions of people
millions of jobs and Biden raising some
eyebrows with what he's saying to
potential voters concerned about the
Tara Reid allegation well I think they
should vote their heart and if they
believe Tara Reid they probably
shouldn't vote for me I wouldn't vote
for me if I believed Tara Reid the fact
is that look at tyre Reid's story it
changes considerably Kennedy for a long
time the Democrats especially if you
remember during the Cavanaugh hearings
and the me2 movement when it was at its
height the mantra was to believe all
women and now Joe Biden is basically
saying if you believe her don't vote for
me is that basically showing that he is
not going to answer in any other way
that he is saying this absolutely did
not happen he's not cracking on any of
that
no Annie's saying that he doesn't
believe her therefore she must be lying
and I wish someone would pose that
question to him specifically do you
think that Tara Reid is lying because
what he's doing here essentially is
victim shaming and it is a gross
perversion of the mutually accepted
rules of me too particularly when they
were applied to the Kavanagh hearing and
I don't think he has answered this very
well also as far as Joe Biden
campaigning from his basement what he's
trying to do right now is use the
pandemic to get out of the debates and I
think the debates are going to be
critical because we we have to see
spontaneous moments to make sure the
person who's going to lead the free
world can do so and can respond to
Barb's and intellectual challenges so
far Joe Biden has really been protected
from that and he's doing these
interviews pretty much with fairly
friendly reporters Greg
he you know he has that little gasps a
little mess up at the beginning mixing
up the deaths versus the jobs numbers
but I'm not sure how he gets better at
any of this before he would have to face
President Trump in a debate before the
election yeah the way he gets better is
not being seen he's the only candidate
in history where the strategy is less is
more
imagine having a product where
advertising is a bad idea you know hey
guys research shows the more people
learn about our cod-liver yogurt the
more they hate it that's Joe Biden which
is why he's hidden in the basement like
granny and Evil Dead 2 not sure if it
was the granny or the mother I'll get
back to that it is ironic that the
what's threatening the American public
is offering immunity to Joe the pandemic
but lucky for Joe living in a pandemic
even if there's no professional baseball
he's still gonna try to get the second
base you know Greg says Jesse that Biden
is benefiting from less is more and
Trump is trying more is more I mean he
is everywhere firing on all cylinders
doing everything that he possibly can
talking to reporters like six times
today well the press was able to hear
from him make the contrast is striking
because that's what Trump he has what it
takes Biden just doesn't have what it
takes he doesn't even believe in himself
if you listen to his answers he's not
even fighting for the votes he's like
you know if you don't believe me vote
for Trump what do I care
like right remember what he used to like
end his speeches he'd be like you know
check me out
if you don't like it vote for the other
guy like there's no confidence that
Biden possesses and that's because he
knows deep down he's not qualified to be
the president he's never been a leader
he doesn't have command of the subject
matter and he's just not articulate
enough to be the leader of the free
world you know we've had such
beautifully articulate presidents for
the in my entire lifetime that you know
they mesmerize you they bring you in
they razzle dazzle you and you can't
stop listening to them talk Biden you
just can't wait
till it's over and and he's gonna have a
tall mountain to climb because sooner or
later this pandemics gonna end and he's
gonna have to get out there yeah one
does it you know it's presidents I've
understood presidential candidates need
to show fire in the belly but I mean do
we have an ember in the belly here in
the Biden campaign boy I thought he was
pretty strong you know we were talking
about that Tara Reid statement I think
that was a fiery statement a very clear
statement that he didn't do it and he is
denying it in the most uncompromising
terms if you think that she's telling
the truth go for it but I'm telling you
it didn't happen I don't know how you
can be any more clear than that so yes I
think there is fire in the belly and I
think that I think that he has been very
strong on that point
he's denied it over and over and the
reporting that's come out since you know
Vox I saw today a piece but it was done
by PBS they interviewed dozens of people
nobody's backing up this the claim the
allegation yet so we'll see where it
goes but not yet and on the gaffes thing
I don't think it was it up I don't think
it was Biden I don't hang on I don't
think it was Biden who said that his
father was born in Germany I think that
was Donald Trump I don't think it was
Biden who said oh yeah George Washington
captured the airports during the
Revolutionary War I think that was
Donald Trump so I'm just I wonder okay
where's this coming presentation
questions all right